so we're sound with this pitch yes I
shall watch it real quick what's your
Frankenstein I'd really like to send it
to you privately and now that come
thanks alright you know you said the
other day you love Frankenstein I too
love Frankenstein and to me it's already
full go on put your glasses back on why
you keep quiet
one of my favorite Frankenstein
characters the Boris call if one of 1931
so I thought of a concept on where I
could take the nostalgic Boris Karloff
monster and bring him back into a modern
day film I don't need to see what you're
saying well to around you mean to like
through a special effects Boris Karloff
right here's the deal it's 2008 and it's
a disfigured orphan and like the
Frankenstein monster he's made fun of
every day and he's tormented and the
only solace he finds in life is by
watching Boris Karloff and because he
relates because like the monster he's
misunderstood he grows up to become a
scientist and he develops a DNA
reprocessing mechanism where he could
take skin and organs and regenerate it
all right so he uses that own process on
himself and he fixes his face and he
becomes this really good-looking
scientist but at the same time he's his
soul is still damned I want to kill
myself
he decides that he's gonna use his DNA
invention dig up the bones of Boris
Karloff himself all right and bring him
back to life as the Frankenstein monster
takes the monster to kill the kids who
tormented him when he was a disfigured
orphan no III gotta tell you something
what I want I want to hang myself from
that pitch he knows it's the actor but
he's he's gone mad it doesn't matter who
played Frankenstein there's no kiss but
Boris Karloff is brought back to life
he's gonna be Boris Karloff
good money do I have to put up for this
that he would tell it to you let me
pictures the pitch is terrible meets
awful not only is it ridiculous I don't
care about the scientist no but the fact
that he digs at Boris Karloff to kill
children the movies that's the beauty of
it but Boris Karloff was an actor Sal
you know he played a character no I do
but the thing is in these type of movies
you have to dismiss a lot of things like
we all know a spider that bites Peter
Parker really can't make him climb walls
but but that's a fantasy film I think
fans who love the 1931 Frankenstein if
you can envision a modern-day divorce
call off monster in a movie today
it's cool it's the story makes no sense
all right thank you
bringing back Boris all right thank very
catchy all right good luck with the film
I'm past I have no luck with the film I
have no money I have nothing can't even
help that movie nope
thanks al